[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to our Thursday
morning stream my name is Sam and I am
joined by Rob here um we are gonna be
playing some Kingdom Come deliverance
oh I really like this game now okay I so
I like medieval times yeah you're gonna
love this then so I think I'm gonna also
love this game yeah
it's well one it's written with bugs so
it's either either you can manage that
you can kind of deal with just how janky
this game is or you walk away and don't
ever touch it again so this is so I was
gonna say this earlier we had to keep
stopping us ourselves from talking about
the game like minutes ago I think that
everything that was delightfully Genki
about Skyrim when it first came out is
kind of how I'm gonna feel about this I
would say it's that but also it's game
breaking so it's like there's there's a
discussion to be had like I've had
probably epic gameplay and show that at
least my horse here is the button hold
on I might guys I think I might get
ready to Sam she's learning oh yes okay
so it's small jank like you know this
strap going in and out of his right
thigh
but flipping in AI sleepin in yeah oh
yeah jitter Easter there are game
breaking bugs and those you can't really
argue before because there's nothing
like you know losing 45 minutes of play
due to like one time I was I was
sprinting and I like went to my menu
like that and then when I came back my
horse was on a mountain and I flew off
and died oh wow yeah so did you like hit
a rock was it just like some physics
stuff what did you just it just warped
my horse into the mountain
it definitely wasn't intentional and it
didn't feel like historically accurate
at all this is a game and I really like
it it's you know it is Skyrim just no
magic you know it's it's more of a
historical look during the 1400s
it's brutal it's intense yes immersive
it lacks the the high fantasy that often
comes with this time period in games but
I think that's probably a good thing
yeah yeah it's good it's relaxing it's I
don't yeah you mean as far as
a realistic sim it's definitely that but
anyways let's get to it so we can do so
many things so how many things have you
done oh I've done a lot of things in
this game but let's do some side quests
so I have some things I've been saving
like I don't do that one actually let's
do so you can date you can date this
girl named Teresa and it's not going so
well yeah that's fine
let's visit no I want to try to date
Teresa a courtship sidequest sounds very
interesting right let's see I think it's
about time I hit her up new texture high
iron freighter hello Bob Jones we're
good today thank you for coming to the
stream somebody here and the chat says
it takes from check history which would
make sense because one of the developers
is from the Czech Republic yeah you know
so do you know much much about the story
of this game or the set up the actual
setup of the plot yeah not a whole I
know that there is it's like a ruler
there's some controversy over a ruler
not a controversy that's like normally
how it goes in medieval times there's a
king and it's like oh he's a bad king I
like sure people don't like the king or
like these other guys should be Kings
pretty much there's only a few options
you have for medieval so pretty much
nailed it so a king a king dies and
someone tries to overthrow the entire
homey Holy Roman Empire and your home
town gets completely pillaged and your
parents die and you're nobody you don't
even know how to read Wow yeah so you
you try to avenge your parents and then
your dad was a sort of blacksmith and he
takes some guys take your sword
it's a redemption story now and so you
ended up here
this is Miller's like a Miller
coincidentally works at a mill that
makes sense because that's like how it
worked right like black blacksmiths like
that was like the names the last names
often followed the you know jobs that
you had exactly so your name ended in
barber that's what you're doing right
okay like so you're like great
great-great-great-great grandfather he
was probably a barber
exactly yeah she looks real bored so her
yeah girl so her and her dad kind of
take you in and I even had a girlfriend
in this like a town I was at and yeah
she died too oh yeah so you're really
starting fresh so she's cool she's nice
she's actually from the town she's a
survivor as well okay cool so we both
have that trouble that we make eye
contact you don't know maybe women
weren't meant to it supposed to look at
them I think you're right
I'm gonna go what there's a historical
choice being made here yeah a lot of
blindfolding turned up the volume a
little bit that's good hold on I think
and I think and just where that might
that be that's like a little flirtatious
wearing my armor how far are you into
the game how far am i into the game yes
I think I've played about maybe 12 hours
once the game opens up you know there's
there's a lot of talk to be had around
like the this lengthy ass tutorial where
the game is just not really present and
now the game is open up for me or has
for a while and that's where you the
people playing the office everyone has
kind different stories because so many
other things so like you can follow the
main quest right now this is a side
quest okay dating where's she going
Teresa you're taking energy the broken
wheel tavern that sounds like a romantic
spot yeah you know what I don't I don't
feel like I'm dressed for the part so
let's take off some of this armor ooh I
like this helmet that you have on no
it's pretty dope it's actually like an
enemy helmet you'll be a pikmin yeah
a metal Pikmin of metal Pikmin yeah
Richard McDonald agrees he's being coy
by not looking at you she's just playing
hard to get it's over yeah oh this is
she loves doing this she's a really
funny person she
this is good oh she's gone oh I was
trying to look I was trying to look at
her eyes the Cape just she's gone man
she's gone you drew she doesn't like men
who jump fences okay so reminiscent of
my real-life dating you're talking and
then disappears she's gone
yeah she's go stood on you she go stood
wow that's a bummer rob killed her did I
did I like is that question is that
quest now just completely gone maybe you
can start it again but she straight
disappeared this is kind of game
breaking yeah yeah I heard it's kind of
unfortunate because I actually haven't
had something like this in a really long
time and I am praising the game but this
hoof this is uh she like she's gone is
she just like it's not available
anywhere [ __ ] she disappeared she's not
like there should be an icon on the map
Charles should I revert to uh say maybe
you should seek the witches they
definitely have something to do with
this something won't be right there Rob
what did you do
Corrine Larkin I got a revert I mean
right definitely
I don't want to continue playing and
rage have recent have missed a sidequest
like that what if you get no other shots
that love you I can't live with that
uh yeah I got it I gotta see this
through also you should go to like a
different dimension is there there you
know I always wondered about this like
when things break in games and things
like fall through platforms and
disappear is there like a proper name
for the place where they go like do game
devs have a lingo upside-down right it's
like the upside down of games you know
like when you fall through the floor you
keep falling and you're like where am i
it's totally that I have Vince it's
creepy that happened in the last Mass
Effect Andromeda game I was playing with
my friend and we felt we like fell
through a actual planet and then like
went into space
oh really yeah it was crazy
like floating around yes wants that fun
I don't I mean look she's just trying to
have a good time thinking about this
game is yeah it's it's weird I mean
they're just trying to clearly talk to
you yes or no yeah yeah they really want
to be clear okay all right we're gonna
turn up hold on wait don't leave she
walks into the fence I'm the fence again
she's probably supposed to walk over
there oh no oh wait there we go okay so
I think what happened earlier do you
remember how you knocked into her in
that last rewrite saying was my phone
definitely she was like how dare you
like like when you knock into the mace
they react yeah so when you knock tinder
she just she she was like no he's rude
dip yeah definitely you know a quick
treats I walk into this fence
she hasn't looked at me once go through
the chat a little bit Johnny Davis it's
kind of boring I don't know I thought
you could argue scarf can be pretty
boring right it's all about like how I
guess how you play it you know
sure um yeah definitely it's not like
there's this is dating sim there's
brutal combat - yeah the really tricky
to be honest after we're done with
medieval dating sim will go and jump
into some combat maybe definitely yeah
this looks like it's about to get real
cray they're on a date I'm invested in
their relationship shredding yeah
it's not that good really I know she's
getting cray
I never say crane you're right oh
they're dancing Oh guys that is very
forward in medieval times I imagined it
could you have to keep in mind like
Christianity is like this is the this is
this right post you know crusade time
right so unorthodox totally now you
can't stop that weird
Jamie dabble in just wait until the mod
say cough Oh Devin that happened it
would be really funny if you could guy
like I agree if you could pursue any of
the people in the game that would be
hilarious but probably take a lot of
work for sure oh I sense a fight
hell yeah sure I have a pretty good
feeling I wanna be fighting this guy
great one thing about this game is that
it's really a reflection well I guess of
the fourteen hundreds in that like just
the vulgarity I guess yeah yeah yeah I
read this but it's a definitely a vulgar
game it doesn't add anything back yeah
but that was you know medieval times are
pretty brutal it was like people would
stab each other over bread so oh yeah
that's right you show him who's boss Rob
what's up but talk to my lady like that
she's more literally in the evil times
she would be or a sec so historically
accurate just just just finding
ourselves in the chat here oh ho
no problem he was drunk though ooh hello
700 views on periscope thank you for
joining us today well we're on a
medieval date oh is this connected to
periscope it is we are well the chats
not connected the periscope but we we do
have people talking us on there and
Khaleesi plays will relay anything
any messages they have for us if they're
important yeah yeah shove that sponge
into my eyes what's really happening is
that you learn later that she's a
straight blind okay so this goes into a
thought that I had that I've been
thinking about for a long time in
medieval times and I don't know about
like wine glasses like became as
advances there now where we can see
perfectly with them the bifocal yes in
medieval times when people had poor
vision did they just think that they
were stupid like you if you like lived
your life and you never could really
like figure out things because you
couldn't see like did they just think oh
yeah he's just like he's a special one
like we don't know why he doesn't know
how to read but we tried he doesn't know
what letters are I think I think you're
absolutely on point and you know what
you probably died a little earlier than
everyone else
oh absolutely like you don't see any of
those glasses on in the medieval times
yes we never seen it no I don't think
glasses were around then and I have not
done my research is it maybe a bad
student if they try to see just this I
don't know I don't know when glasses
became a thing that changed changed the
game for a lot of people there it is
milady oh she gave a little side look
there she was like hey smile oh no he's
just like where do you buy this game on
PC you buy this on Steam it's also on
ps4 and Xbox I'll be honest you know
again it's a matter of like if you can
look past the bugs and the glitches we
had clearly a game breaking one just
earlier if you are interested and that's
a worry like there's nothing wrong with
like waiting a few months yeah and you
know hopefully they'll patch out a lot
of this stuff yes yes so see Teresa's
back out in the rain all he does by the
way is just bring a bag from here and he
brings another one back to there that's
that's what he does every day every day
and his hat just appear
and his hat will it disappear if he
walks away further oh it's gone it's
gone oh and that's that goes for
everyone - like Theresa will probably
change clothes in a second
really yeah what's our faraway clothes
and our clothes there is you see it it's
like black everyone has like a default
like set of clothes as our in distance
what's our use that yeah where we going
I was gonna ask you sure
killed a camp leader how does that sound
yes okay let's do it cute so my my view
of the mid of the medieval times is very
warped by movies and television and two
of my favorite movies of all time and
one of Heath Ledger's most underrated
movies of all time is a Knight's Tale I
I've seen it I don't remember it I don't
remember it Rob sorry was that
historically accurate take that back
don't they play like like ac/dc it's
amazing like during a jousting scene
it's so good so you need that's your
homework for today okay and then also
the Monty Python and holy girl
oh absolutely one of the best for sure
and I would be lying if I wasn't hoping
that there would be a Monty Python
reference hidden somewhere in here yeah
you're probably a point like like a name
of an area or something like that a name
a joke all right I did this earlier this
was a gift on Twitter um I posted let's
see if I can have to have it happen
again
go go gadget knows what's up a night
sale is amazing thank you God and Bob
Jones as well also Bob Jones did a
little research for us up there I'm
gonna go look the firt the first
eyeglasses were made in northern Italy
most likely in Pisa by about 1290 from
Google huh well you know it would make
sense that they were they were probably
expensive they were probably really and
regular people probably couldn't afford
them so I'm really not Henry here right
Henry was not gonna have glasses and his
friends were also probably not gonna
have glasses and everyone he knew
probably not gonna and if you did have
glasses you'd probably get shanked
stolen in brutal times brutal times
what errand law says this game is Game
of the Year contender even with the
controversy you know I'm gonna what okay
so in the town and not yours you were
required to hold a torch so I just like
fast forwarded time so I could talk to
this man what he called sure no
merchants but during that time lapse I
got called out by the cop local police
force Wow I have to pay 10 bucks
fighting him obviously okay it won't end
well
it won't no are you sure I mean I'm not
trying to mess up your game what happens
if you fight him and you don't win do
you just die they throw me in jail oh
that's not good well your lady leave you
raised escape mistakes look at Henry
with this rebel right here really happy
about toilets changed the entire game
for Humanity yeah um they show the
toilet it's basically just a wooden hole
that you sit on a bench and there's by
the way it's just in the middle of a
hallway there's no there's no privacy
just like hi how you doing hey what's up
just yeah I don't think I can find one
so I'll just have to pay cheese I know I
made empty threats before I didn't mean
anything I just said here's your money
so the I don't know if this will be game
of the year staff I will have to see how
it progresses yeah how the fans pick up
because like you know it is kind of a
niche thing you know a medieval medieval
is not for everybody so it might even if
it does really well I don't know if it
will be massively well-received because
of the time period it really will have
to see yeah I think um I don't know I
really do like this King
there's cool there are cool moments
within it like if you can if you can
like again handle the bugs and glitches
and stuff this I feel like this is a
game I would really enjoy
yeah absolutely like when we get when we
get into like the woods it's pretty neat
like there's not like a like a constant
threat like it's very peaceful in a way
right and I I mean I did hear some
criticism about like the women
characters being very flat and boring
and but like I'm you know it was the
medieval times I'm not saying that women
did not have compelling stories but they
were definitely not a WoW Revere yeah
they weren't really allowed to have
compelling story and seriously they did
there are some incredible stories from
women at that time but yeah I wouldn't
be it I wouldn't necessarily expect that
to be in an RPG about from medieval
times you know like wasn't a really
empowering time for anybody yeah
Christianity the the Crusades it just
happened the Black Plague like you know
it was freaking freaking white collar
elites in their high castle
yeah totally totally this is like brutal
forever it was not a fun time to really
be alive actually yeah shout out to the
ancestors who survived so now okay
finally for those wondering what the
hell I'm doing I'm finally able to talk
to someone I guess this town was just
like passed out until noon it's been a
sweet party so I need food so this is
like survivals type stuff so I'm losing
energy I need some nourishment actually
I need a sleep this game is really
brutal nothing is like if I hold on to
an apple for like more than four days it
goes rotten if you eat it you get sick
why it life apples yeah I better eat it
quick bear meat can go sour if that's
what hair hat yeah rabbit rabbit meat
rabbit meat so I'm just buying some food
because I'm gonna need it yes yes you
like yep Snyder's yeah
gube says what up salmon hot Rob how's
it going buds Rob how you doing I rubbed
I'm so good hot great
didn't buy this alright here we go I
forgot you have to like a guy likes it
oh this isn't any game so don't expect
perfection yeah that's fair well that
doesn't mean indie games can't be
perfect there's a lot of times and he's
pull out some amazing games but there's
something to be said that when an indie
game is $60 there should be a precedent
totally upon launch so definitely being
said this is a weird lunch I'm having
here okay let's close this deal so you
can haggle them you can you can haggle
the price every time so this has
apparently it also I'm not very clean
right now I got like blood all over my
face yes it will affect my haggle
abilities will it make you a lesser
better better or worse at haggling worse
even my attire so if I'm like trying to
like haggle a like nobleman I should be
dressed for the part oh that's kind of
cool I do like that that is I thought
they would fear you and because you're
covered in blood and maybe they would
that's a good point right like maybe
they would go oh he's bait he's based in
the blood of his enemies just rubs
little horse dung all over my face right
it's not enough Macari says women had a
lot of power in the medieval times in
charge of food and pantry basically the
economy any servants they had that is
very interesting and I definitely need
some read up on some of the medieval
time stuff history see how I feel after
playing the game yeah I'm not on that
one too actually no I'm not either that
that's you know we don't learn a whole
lot about medieval times no okay so this
is this is part of the game apologies
for not showing combat so quickly but
like you just got it yeah you have to
save all the time you have to eat all
the time it's like real life troll Mao
says I don't like the combat it is
complex and that is a good point but
it's too slow I think that really tough
isn't there like a kind of a curve a
curvature with like in the beginning
it's really hard because you're kind of
a you're just scrapping you know sort of
you're yeah you're you're not a skilled
fighter you're not warrior or anything
like that
absolutely like in your it starts off
like that yeah you're like inexperienced
exactly and you do training and stuff
and then eventually you get better at it
until it isn't so difficult anymore I
think it's like that's it from what I
read in our review you wish you guys
should check out on the website
Capeside back home reviews tab and
deliverances there then from what I read
he said it does get much easier after
the learning curve yeah so and the
experience is gained so I would say like
if you feel like it's a little bit
frustrating maybe give it some more time
and yeah it's I'm still not great with
it I mean it's this game has meant to be
difficult but there are ways of choosing
it like I found one where if i if I'm on
horse back I can just like shoot an
arrow at someone and they'll continually
chase me and I just got away a little
bit and shoo narrow gallop away and they
just keep chasing you yelling out like
get back here you live it
Lily liver which is a thing I guess back
in the day oh and apparently I read this
earlier the horses are like there's
levels of horses like these horses are
good these horses are bad like you can
like oh really yeah like there are you
can like I guess selling buy horses
someone who's selling horses it's
probably over here somewhere
anyways that's interesting yeah yeah I'm
not surprised I just saw that also when
I was perusing all so sorry everybody
that probably sounded crazy
this is my horse on the mic Oh pebbles
has these pebbles really I wish I named
him paddle pebbles what's his name
actually alright that's it
he doesn't have a name no that is his
name pebbles oh oh okay can you name
them no oh it may be that gave me this
horse maybe you could have named him
when he was given to you or was his name
already decided for you I mean I guess
he just grew into it and I wasn't able
to change born born pebbles but that
would be interesting if you could meet
me horses okay
we're ours Winthrop give him a classroom
name um bargains has got to go thank you
for joining us bargain on YouTube we
appreciate you okay we're off so I can't
fast travel there some I got it I had
hit the trail
Macari says yes your character does get
better over time he will and he will get
better at it like he starts to shake
less with archery that's good to know oh
yeah because archery there isn't even
like a reticle or a crosshair yeah
really tough to shoot arrows but yeah
I've definitely gotten better because
you like the more you do stuff the more
you kind of earn skills for it our our
review gave the game an 8 I believe just
letting you guys know and there are no
political motivations there it is is an
8 based on the game ok so let's see
where I'm going here no I took an
off-ramp hey back on the freeway horse
horse the horse of course what if you
use named your horse horse that that's
pretty good just horse like his horse
whatever his horse how many weapon types
are in the game there's a sword there's
definitely a sword I think there's a
long sword a short sword fat sword a
blue sword oh there is like and I was
like maybe there's a knife there's a
dagger there's like axes bow and arrow
two-hand bow and arrow
two-handed like one-handed I guess
that's actually long long and short
swords
damn it over there so I agree with you
Macari so much I person I love games
that take place in different time
periods
it's what sort of drew me to Assassin's
Creed which I didn't play enough of his
house inscri but I just loved I loved
like being stuck in different times and
I don't know I always like to circle
fiction when I was growing up I just
liked history I think it's so
interesting to see how people lived so
so long ago and here not so long ago
like the last hundred years it was
pretty crazy we we advanced very quickly
a lot of improvement yeah quality of
life went way way up I mean just look at
like the iPhone generation that's right
yeah every year there's something like
better to be had yes
so a time without technology it's very
interesting
okay so I'm creeping up on this bandit
camp now things are really gonna heat up
it's gonna get coming in hot come in
real hot okay so I got a kill the camp
leader this is kind of like your are you
how are you going what's your plan of
attack
sorry to interrupt no you're fine I I
can't like they all come at you on foot
so I might do my spamming trick where I
get on a horse cuz pebbles here can
spawn whenever I want
so you do a lot of cool things like I
can wait at night when they're all
sleeping or I can just try now I don't
have a see the one thing about this game
you can't just like save anywhere right
no you have to have Savior snaps snaps
which is something you buys you have to
buy saves or you sleep so but sleeping
doesn't you can't safely asleep at any
given time right no I have to like find
a bed oh you can't just like sleep on
the ground ooh are you gonna perch
yourself up there and just like this
night no scopez what's up dudes Mon is
Henry and I know scope wow they don't
believe in you at all Rob Devon Gibson
says prepare to see Rob die that's fine
wow man I should have had I should have
gone a schnapps so I could save here
wait I thought it was close I don't know
what I just did dude what you do know
right I figured it out it's all good
[ __ ]
can you shoot yourself with an arrow you
know I'm gonna say probably I don't know
if you can do that in real life okay I'm
gonna say like oh no oh you're come on
again get him nice get that worse
Oh totally there the whole time get on
that horse run after him chase him down
oh wow he's really run well you think
you're going just hit him with the horse
can you run him over now you I wish and
you shot your horse in the head that
would be sad yeah that would suck
come on prove me wrong win Rob why GG
Rob you're dead all right
no it's it's totally eight like the 1400
this is like how they fought yes the
tournament arrow oh this is the one oh
he's getting out he's running out of
breath oh stop whoa Nellie
isn't this realistic you got this
I believe all right I'm low I'm low what
does that mean I mean like I'm shooting
low I got actually a little higher like
that oh yeah nice stop it oh right in
the butt I think maybe his butt it
definitely is stuck in his butt look at
that
I'm running out of arrows here alright a
soul says this demystify ya
oh wait no I think we're using like this
multi chat window that's using of like
weird character emojis
so those Rob can you confirm that those
might look like fires so you're
absolutely right that looks a lot like
fire oh I was distracted then I lost him
Sam I'm sorry [ __ ] oh good but confirmed
they do kind of like viruses oh no they
totally do dang it he had like three of
my best arrows in his butt I know you're
aiming weird arrows find out oh its toe
is that an airless sword great no wow
looking at oh I'm really running low on
arrows here I didn't think that would
ever happen he's rocking it I just shot
an arrow in here guys piercing dude can
you take the arrow back oh I guess I did
because that that would be hyper
realistic if you could take the arrow
back you can't so yeah okay he's got a
couple arrows in his in his body I'm
gonna reclaim them alright he's
surrendering oh my god that was amusing
also oh my goodness alright it's a foot
chase him with that okay I gotta get him
with the do you don't have an axe cuz I
feel like this is an axe I know it was
too heavy I got this sword
we put my sword on my helmet cuz I'm oh
that's okay he's dead Rob he's dead Rob
sorry blacked out alright let's see here
uh let's take his ear because that's
might not snack for later the worst that
was amazing
I can't believe somebody goes copy that
said what I call PETA what did horsey do
to deserve that that was in spine look
at he's fine I don't think he's fine
just because he's not talking about it
okay I'm running into a bug oh no not
this guy had some deer meat on him
alright so what I do is I just take all
his clothes
that's messed up oh I can take his body
I can throw it somewhere
no I can't very I can just drop it
[Laughter]
horses right there you don't need to
whistle at it to the horse it's it's
frustrating because the horse whistle
and mounting are the same key oh okay so
so that's why that happens she probably
thinks you're a nag what I'm here
God what do you want now it's me pebbles
I'm here it's me pebbles
I think that's pebbles voice I'm just
like narrate for pebbles hey pebble
lots alright so a little sidetracked
yeah we did we did was that the guy we
were supposed to go nope oh yeah it sad
well he was a bad dude okay that's
better
hungry Hobbit welcome to my street or to
the game saw stream thank you so much
for joining today and yes it is it was a
bit violent I got a little a little
shook there
sina weibo who's rob lowes overkill he
does you got to make sure dampers okay
count pickles welcome as well that guy
has no head oh wait that guy has a head
the other one does not have a head
though at all oh there it is okay
hey no no let's use a wounding arrow so
I guess there's different types of
arrows that are stronger yeah they are
not reacting to you at all they are so
close they're one in the same now maybe
you'll shoot through both of them
run run can pebble can they hurt pebbles
they probably can I don't that's good
question they probably can you you know
it's not annoying are these Birds does
pebbles have a health bar I don't even
know I don't know I don't think so I'm
concerned for her let's use this better
hunting arrow oh that was a see this is
like totally cheesing it I don't have to
like go on foot and die
oh he's done always gone look at this
okay get off you can definitely finish
them yes
oh he's running oh they pull you off the
horse they don't kill the horse hell
yeah nice all right God all right let's
try this out I don't know how well them
to do dude it is time oh I like that
slow down that was cool yeah so you like
Dave Jewett from the UK was telling me
how to how to do this like you you
really have to do like the just like oh
you'll see the shield prompt in the
middle of the crosshair and when I hit
that I can like I can get a stun by
blocking Wow
oh no oh oh no yeah yeah yeah that's
right
well yeah hell yeah hell yeah let's take
his ear first things first I like how
it's the first item all right let's take
your ear off it's just like the first
available choice it is let's take some
arrows yeah oh yeah they will be
throwing their swords like in sword art
online I don't know I don't know was it
can they throw their swords in this game
I don't think so I don't yeah I don't
think so he'll be crazy like throwing
daggers at people what are we playing
this on we were playing on PC right now
PC that's right
are you want the PC Gamer Rob um you
know it's a good question
you don't ask myself that every day I
don't really know I'd I would I mean
we're lucky enough to like kind of have
a lot of platforms here at our disposal
right I definitely started my life out
of this console yeah same evolved yeah
you thought well I'm not trying to say
anything bad about consoles I love my
ps4 but right you know I think a lot of
it is due to like I used to play a lot
more PC games but now my rig at home is
kind of outdated yeah I'm real outdated
ooh yeah yeah I am I think I started
getting into playing games on PC when I
started getting into more indie games
and stuff mm-hmm I realized there were
just so many options for interesting
games on Steam I didn't it like kind of
blew my mind how many games there were
back I'm talking like when I first
started getting into it yeah
18:19 that was ages I was like oh my god
there are thousands of games literally
thousands all this time I had no idea
I only thought I only knew what there
wasn't game stock no like hey yeah
definitely right you're in sucks he was
standing there with like no the arrow
went past I'm no reaction that man is
coming for you did you just shoot him
for no reason I kind of shot him in the
groin area for no reason at all
you just did it because these are
bandits okay all right they need to be
murdered oh okay I'm with you several
times there's a lot of murdering this
game look at this guy
what an idiot he's walking into a hill
physics that best to take advantage of
this I think I think he's gonna flee
forever this way
so confused turns around slowly draws a
sword
yeah come at me wait now his fist he
draw he drew his fists come on let's go
oh whoa he's trying to take your horse
maybe is Rob Canadian no my Canadian
yeah no answered that look at this
yeah right and her friend dome right
through the helmet pinned it to his head
oh look he loves it
get the ear I wonder if you can collect
ears that maybe it's like an achievement
no you bring it back to the so this guy
where I got this initial quest from he
loves ears so I just gave him all these
ears he's like thanks here's money I'm
like I bet I wonder if that was a thing
back yeah I think so Elia trophy trophy
kill Bob Jones are you still there
Google is already our resident resident
medieval experts Bob Jones back checking
ears trophies okay well search histories
about to get real weird alright so that
worked out I am surprised I would have
died chat thought I was going to die but
I did not come ENT says can you play as
a female character - no it's it's it's
it's a pretty linear narrative in the
sense that you're Henry and you are
Henry it's a redemption story okay so I
got a lot of stuff and trying to drop
this is kind of boring but deal with me
okay let's drop these old boots let's
drop this quick off boys boys I don't
know what that is
yeah that's a hat I guess ah all this
forget okay sweet oh my god these birds
now I go back to town here and I give
the ears to this dude
so this fast travel that's kind of cool
do you like mm-hmm
it'll pop up it should pop up like a
random kind of like a random event and I
can choose whether I want to engage it
like right here let's do it what is it
wait for we'll find out oh oh hi hello
man hello beggar how are you it's like
six gestures that everyone shares nice
they had to you know it's cautious
cost-efficient mm-hmm exactly
you just turn it down yeah I talked to
him again sorry I definitely believe you
this time yeah this time the line didn't
work on me the first but heard it again
revised it I'm I've bought I bought this
dude's died before I know this guy gube
says those bird sounds are horrifying
they are I think what cicadas also I
feel like I earned
[Music]
oh wow look at those Bob Jones coming
through they determined that there were
five individuals from this region that
showed evidence of compound scalping
involving the removal of the ear the
first was a 20 to 30 year old male that
dated from 1200 to 1400 seee
and evidence for removal was only found
on the left ear from the internet wow
man
thank you so yeah you can have Jones
come through come through that's pretty
interesting those birds are smart
beeping suspicious Lulu died okay fine
he won't let me hey go should I kill him
he's a beggar he's probably you're not
gonna let you hang all that should I
kill him just doing watching I mean I
guess you can't he's smiling though Rob
I can't do it he's like looking up at
you with a childlike smile and you would
just lay him like that look at him he's
so nice he's kind of suspicious that's a
suspicious smile see I've got this plan
Z all right let's go is there so if you
just like kill people for no reason does
that affect you at all in the game yeah
you have like reputation if you will for
like each one these towns so you go
around just killing people and then save
or you know continue on that path yeah
like they'll hate you
nice it's yeah God you jump so high on
horse
alright so watch this guy take all my
ears I have what's up it's good thing
you stopped in Ville says look at this
man you don't sound like you are this
car like they're probably a handful of
characters in this that do not sound
English fourteen hundred I am glad to
see you there is this one I tweeted
there's like this this one detective
kind of quests and you'd give him the
evidence and he goes that is [ __ ]
suspicious
[Laughter]
inflection is just like not there at all
yeah hand over the trophy is yeah buy
trophies I mean ears
you're my ear man ear man three years
thank you I wear these I took care that
camp he really liked the inflection of
this man's voice it's creepy and weird
doesn't make it doesn't sound like how
people talk at all do you have the
things that I am looking for prove it to
me it's just clearly in a vo booth
there's like yep first take that sounds
good for your time here you're good you
are good all right let's go to question
I missed you I missed you so much
great next do you have my ears I don't I
do course you have again
can you murder everyone in a town for
their ears and so that further to the
sky
that's a great question right class I
don't think so it's only like the
kyumin's who are like the the main
antagonists group of enemies I want to
see a playthrough where you kill every
single person you encounter I mean it's
kind of like it's kind of like any kind
of I don't know like open-world GTA SA
thing we're like more people what appear
more people will appear and you'll just
get over overrun got it but I want I was
hoping that you would just kill
everybody there'd be nobody left except
you an ear man you kill everything like
like 200 ears
oh my god right that's that's the game I
want to see ears for years this is a guy
like here's four years all right so
let's do this
main questline here mysterious ways
there's gonna be a nice ride I guess so
let's see here
so you can fast travel but yeah fast
travel but why not oh well no I mean I
can only go so far okay I want to see
wait
so from where you are now we're just
gonna hoof it no
so I'll fast travel sorry I'll fast
travel so like Homburg and then from
there we'll book it yeah I wonder so
okay controversial opinion hmm riding
horses and games for long periods of
time is boring now
some people love it I'm gonna I'm gonna
get more specific here
so Red Dead Redemption I loved that game
for a lot of reasons but riding my horse
around made me not bored I got so bored
I was like yeah I get it it's the Wild
West cool we're in a desert yeah sweet
wow that's a beautiful Vista ooh ah you
know and then you would go and you kill
somebody and it would be like okay go
back to where you robbed no it's okay I
didn't see any coffee spill guys robbed
just destroyed everything in this room
sorry sorry York
Eric runs in here and then they're like
okay turn back around and you're like I
gotta go all the way back all right here
we go
gallop gallop gallop sorry we got the
paperwork wrong yeah I go back to the
town right and that would happen so
often in that game and I just got kind
of so I do like the fact that you can
fast track in this place in this game a
lot yeah but yeah I don't know it's each
their own and I totally feel yeah like I
played a handful of Red Dead I actually
didn't finish it which is embarrassing
today but I will before the second comes
out but that being said yeah I I totally
feel yeah I like it
this game is I think I don't know I
think part of it too is like the
first-person aspect I think that really
has a lot to do with it where you really
do feel you know yeah like you're
actually in the woods on horse yeah that
that helps but I I feel like you can't
do that forever you've got to kind of
make it your own like I have make it
make it entertaining for yourself like
shoot arrows while you're doing it right
or kill a person kill a random person
while you're doing commit random acts of
violence spice it up spice up your life
if you get bored just kill somebody
you're bored just kill someone it's fine
it's fine I like all these puns that are
going on in the chat lend me your ears
Steven oh what's that from get in the
panderdome lend me your ears from
Bellbrook smoothie I mean lend me your
ears
is all the ears really yeah I think that
that's really a thing that happened in a
movie as a joke oh that means I'm Mel
Brooks I think it's men in tights Zig
nice don't so let me your ears and it
just gets just throw like dozens of
years oh that's that's funny I went back
to sleep
get up you pass yeah Ericka's is gonna
have a word with you Robin it's fine
it's bye we just need cupholders in here
the auto ride in The Witcher was helpful
and the one beaming says yes this game
is supposed to have it but it doesn't
work we're supposed to be little
probably happen eventually
yeah because that would be cool an auto
ride feature be like oh okay sweet I
like I'm a horse I'll get to me where
I'm going I get to like see the sights I
don't have to do it though I get to go
do dishes in real life yeah or I can
like look at my inventory and like
whatever yeah that's actually that'd be
pretty neat is to like I mean inventory
would pop scuse me no excuse would pause
your game but like I don't know if
there's a way to like yeah have like the
game run while you're doing some
management mhm mhm yes I agree this is
me eating things sounds I don't like the
sound of it
oh you said Cuban not Cuban I was so
confused okay have you been human yeah
like that like the spice all right I'm
all fed CJ says well I feel old she
didn't know what Robin Hood Men in
Tights was no I actually do know what
that is it's a really funny movie yeah
Mel Brooks movies are really awesome um
but yeah I will watch on Netflix also I
you guys don't know how old I am I don't
know if I should tell you on stream but
it would probably surprise you so it's
gonna be 48 I'm gonna be 28 a lot of
people think I'm like 20 but you know
it's all good I turned 30 last year old
man I know old man Rob I was talking
someone like I'm now like I cracked my
elbow the other day I was weird
Oh though that made me feel old I guess
pebbles go okay
Oh goob okay but yes CJ I will give it
to watch okay so we're we going Rob are
we going we're going to this area here
well pebbles are you are you wheeling
are you doing a wheelie right now hey we
can use I will show you could see a
third person I know on it I know or like
take a screenshot in third person I
think that'd be amazing
yeah I'm hoping for a mod that could
there's person mod yeah so I can see
Henry doing a sick wheelie on pebbles
you call those cows for me you can't
kill them you probably can I probably
can I don't think the town will like it
if you kill the cow are they somebody's
cows probably yeah okay these are all oh
geez I'm sorry everybody
these are all important things to
consider yeah you want me to kill it
kind of but like I don't know I'm a
little bit scared I'm gonna be sad oh my
god that one's looking at you
oh no don't kill him don't kill me okay
good call run away
I just realized I don't like having many
arrows I just got my like legit long
distance my piercing I got my tournament
my wounding screw it
oh hi you can jump on this horse nice
ski to trick jumps I can I can jump and
then whistle oh no I can't cuz I'm all
on the horse
so I can jump in then just get off the
horse that's a cool trick Wow cool trick
grab sorry
horse tricks wasn't around why does
pebbles back two legs have wheels it's
like I'm going weird tangent here like
babe in the babe - taking the big city
it was like that one dog was who's he
doesn't have any hind legs so he gives
wheels for hind legs it's really cute I
love that you had that so ready like I
saw babe - hey I like that you
remembered the name also of the sequel
because I definitely saw that when it
came out when I was a kid yeah but you
had that ready you were right yeah I
don't mean I didn't see it like last
week yeah I just play didn't watch it
last night as I go to sleeping movie you
know it might go to sleeping movie as
though this is some really random since
we're here yeah zoo Zoolander that's a
pretty good one I love it I don't know
why I just love that movie I could fall
asleep do mine is I for me it actually
is just the office in general oh yeah
absolutely it's gonna put that on just
something you know right it's something
damn it pebbles you can't jump that
which makes sense this is anti jump in
yeah there's the cat is just as confused
as I am about how you remember that
scene in the the detail of that his
characters likes he's rocking it Oh cuz
any that's what I've had an emotional
impact on the end did but then there was
a one scene where he's like chasing a
car and he bites onto the car with like
a rope and then he like pulls up his
front legs so then he's just he's on
wheels oh you know what I do remember
that you know I knew I didn't know
you're talking about that was pretty
funny
where
okay what are we gonna do what are we
doing you've discovered Baker so is this
the grocer you've discovered a grocer I
like this town so I guess you can go to
the baker and the grocer and get food
imagine
yeah those kind of auto pop up let me
know that I found these things got it do
they become places that you can fast
travel to on the map later on though
specifically the only things I can fast
travel to are just town so you'll go to
like the center of the channel yes these
are all the fast travel things here the
blue okay so Ryan we do read stream
comments we went on a whole tangent here
with the stream babe - babe - bigamous a
pig in the city um oh I just get that I
just got that pun like is it supposed to
be big in the city so it's pig in the
city there you go great
so what are we what kind of quest are we
gonna go on here so there's this guy
earlier in the main story named ginger
and ginger he was kind of like a doofus
and he's he's giving me clues to now
figure out who this limp this bandit has
a limp that's how I know he's he's this
guy I guess it's a good signifier find
out where the limping bandit lives so I
think I'm doing a little interrogation
on the towns folk here do you live
longer if you pray in this game just
wondering no wow you can just pray just
because does it I wonder if praying will
increase your reputation though with God
well with people in the game because the
Christianity didn't matter it's true
there's like if you go to church and you
pray it probably increases your
reputation now let's see if you can be
praying right now I don't know I'm
scratching I personally am bad inside
I'm praying oh that would be interesting
I was just spec spectator or speculating
sorry you know yeah I mean I I think
maybe I think I saw some cutscenes in
like a trailer where it's Henry in a
church giving like a sermon or something
alright I don't know where I'm supposed
to be going here what is this stream for
ants
I can like quote that movie so hard I
think I have the black lung pop / man
man it's so good okay I don't know I
think I'm just going to start talking to
people I guess where is the town this is
creepy talk to them talk you just passed
the person we're here peripheral vision
is bad what are you doing here to take
him away
he lives in a cottage at the end of the
village by the road to retain wow this
is pretty easy
great talk trade though you got anything
good milk a sweet sweet pancake I will
say that some of their faces are quite
distinct that's kind of cool like a
detail and references between characters
even like the NPC's absolutely yeah I
kind of miss hoping that would auto pop
up there it is cool hey boss James s ass
if you can't pray can you at least
burdensome heretics to appease the Lord
you know I have questions these
questions too I don't know I don't know
yet I know about that I did read that
Christianity does play a theme in the in
the game because of the time period or
does play a role it is a theme yeah game
I mean yeah every every person like
every intro dialogue when you talk
someone is just like God be praised so
yeah there's a lot of that
I feel like what am i doing on my
healthier I'm shelling like I say I
should probably sleep in foot
oh okay how did okay how do they know so
we just said good day Henry I don't know
anyone in this town you just got here I
just got here
it's probably like just like one of
those it's like your presence props
prompts the NPC's and then they just
have like a pool of things they can
choose to say to you when one of them is
like hey Henry so if you don't know them
like I just I just guess sorry any ID I
didn't know those actually your name
yeah I mean every other command is named
Henry in the south really though they
probably like the pools of names Michael
Henry Henry Henry with an eye Henrick
Frederick Frederick yeah Bernard Bernard
Bernard don't forget John Ringo twin
nemesis's can you find love than this
game and I just love like like you can
definitely find love yes you can find
love and it's her name's Teresa that's
all I know
she doesn't like looking at you though
Oh
Libby's dead Oh Oh God
oh my god my god they really they
relieved all right
I mean look sensor that sorry Street
wish I knew he was making his Jesus
intestines were pulled out I know that
was like a thing they did that's what we
were talking about murdering four out of
boredom that guy was bored yeah oh yeah
really boring Wow anyone was eating yeah
I think I would have Wow
well fun Wow who was Limpy his hat also
functions as a towel and toilet paper
yeah good point
getting into some kind of trouble
yes Skylark this game can get pretty
mature that's what you explained it that
was a thing they did disembowel people
yeah I mean I don't think that happens
too often anymore no not so much
yeah go with everyone in the background
um yeah I mean you just have to ask all
the objects like well we know we're
giving you options but you have actually
asked these are the things you will say
yeah your choose the order you're saying
it the illusion of choice that's it wait
I just asked these you asked okay so
that's it Wow okay great cool cool
yeah that that does I have to say I
don't love I like only being able to
choose one thing and not being able to
go back to ask all the other options you
know like yeah yeah
it makes your just choice more impactful
for sure it makes it least makes it feel
more impactful whether it is or not
right at least it gives the illusion of
it having impact but when they just are
like here's all the questions that you
can ask and you if you feel like asking
them all you can't I guess yeah it's
like what's the point just like make my
character ask this and I can skip them
you know just have him Auto ask yeah I
just do it for me then yeah at that
point exactly
see if this guy knows anything about
limping good anyone looking forward for
a game on March turn emesis has any any
March games Joe conforte Rob ask you a
few questions
see if thieves and far crimes one five
are the big ones yeah I really want to
see if thieves to be fun I think that
has an opportunity to be really fun to
it like stream and watch people stream
definitely I want to be a pirate generic
pirate
hi far cry 5 yeah really interesting Far
Cry 3 I don't think it plays for
actually tell anybody but or yeah I I
didn't play much of three I plates four
had some fun with that I didn't like
primal fun fact this game is made in
CryEngine 3 which the first Rio is made
in the more you know not many games are
meeting CryEngine I mean like I guess I
don't say not many there's probably a
lot that I made in CryEngine but not a
lot of huge games yes
Sandeep says how big is the map which
are three big I wouldn't say that it's
hard to actually cuz you know that to be
honest I've been fast traveling a lot
yes it's hard to really feel it right
like I would say it's pretty big though
I don't know I I wouldn't say far I
wouldn't say Witcher size I'd say a
comparison I can yeah maybe not Witcher
3 sized no I have to just not
fashionable for a minute you know it was
[ __ ] it let's just do corner to corner
run from one end to the other
we'll watch we'll walk Oh God we'll do
this right oh yes is huge mass so big CJ
says is a mirror this is a pretty stale
year for video game releases I think
it's really early in the year we're only
in February and normally the first half
of any year is pretty slow yeah so I
would say it's not stale yet we're quite
early in the year it's gonna definitely
things are gonna get crazy especially
after e3 mm-hmm with all the games that
are gonna you know a lot of dates of
release dates will happen in June for
this latter half of the year so we're
gonna get more information about all the
big titles and when they're coming out
pretty holiday and all that so it could
get it could get spicy I'm just saying
hold on yeah definitely I mean it's the
year be young and now October has Red
Dead coming out like that month in
general is frames nuts Kingdom Hearts 3
they say is coming out this year I don't
know Kingdom Hearts that well you can
leave nice having out stream Rob
[Laughter]
hopefully let's pray and break in this
person's house
I guess I've seen Cray great yeah like
you never said it before today
well maybe maybe a few times now you
just can't stop now it's my thing all
right I'm gonna be honest this puzzle
looks really dumb dude lock-picking is
not easy in this game I don't
lock-picking in any game lock-picking is
something i never want to do ever get
pedals look casual be on the lookout
whistle if you see anything hey bark mmm
its merits I'll take all nine of your
carrots come on where's the good stuff
CJ says mmm maybe that's what it is we
normally have a good idea of releases
that year in advanced yeah I think it's
just early I mean maybe we haven't heard
you know some cool actually popped up on
reddit after I had you know in this game
they were like each house has one of
these pots okay apparently during this
time you know I think I think like some
cultures still do it but you just have a
stew always going yeah in your house I
mean do you hear that I never knew that
we're basically like you just put
anything in there meat whatever so it
never actually gets rotten or staling it
like that yeah yeah yeah it's always
have like stew Goins hold like hunter
stew or some like that which is pretty
crazy yeah
I actually learned about that in a so I
grew up in New Jersey and there was the
neighborhood and area I grew up in was a
Revolutionary War like army site oh wow
so they had like a reenactment like a
Revolutionary War reenactment camp in my
area and I was pretty calm yeah yeah it
was pretty it was pretty cool
New Jersey has a lot of really cool like
American revolutionary history and stuff
but anyway they taught us about like the
cooking and the eggs they're the daily
life of people in the colonial times in
America I can't fast travel because I
took that guy's stuff a little bit where
is that reputation thank goodness is my
hometown not too good it's it's no
longer existent it's burned to the
ground okay so I don't know why they're
gonna blame me for that yeah it's not
your fault clearly clearly this is
saying it for me so I should sorry I'll
nailed it No so crossing fingers okay
reputation 41 yeah makes sense I wanted
to bring this up earlier we do have I
believe we have an article for every
game that's supposedly coming out this
year it's like every release every game
released in 2018
yeah definitely so check it out see I
was gonna keep dropping articles
[Music]
shamelessly st. shameless games about
self-promotion Oh as your so I some
people I recognize are you stuck on a
fence right now with the whole horse
whole worse is stuck on the fence sure I
just like please share this with the
world at some point eyeballs
this is a beautiful beautiful key help
if you shot her with an arrow do you
think she would fall shudder she did
with an arrow just try really you sure
about this look the game like she's not
even really here yeah she's she's she's
halfway in the upside of I'm really her
but somewhere she'll survive
I don't do her head her neck it's a
little too not her stomach okay
how about we'll start with the tail okay
no shoo the tail probably chewed the
body
that's oh through the tail it's already
all the way in the fields did the button
yeah well I'm also losing arrows all
right I'll use my eyes I won't use my
lose my time I'll use a dumb arrow like
a cheap one though I don't know if they
have those dumb arrows okay wow you
could be a voice actor oh really
yeah that's all I got that's that no
there's got to be more in your
wheelhouse I'm not gonna make you do it
on stream but I'm just saying you don't
get that voice and then no other voices
there's lots of range there what I was
about to say earlier which was just I
see I recognize a lot of you guys from
the last couple Thursday's I've been on
but in the beginning people like Sam who
are you and I was like oh I do social
media for GameSpot follow us on Facebook
and Twitter so I'm gonna do that thing
again where it's like hey if you use
social media and you like to consume our
content like some things gay do it you
that's that is reasonable why can't I go
into this house hey not allowed help
excuse me yes are you stuck in the door
can you back out my horse okay now try
walking in again nope
hey lady hey lady all right let's get
our attention
mania buys my house excuse me miss oh my
god they got our attention this town
isn't really liking me you're everything
you're attacking them oh there she is
Oh Shh Chet puncher oh my god what is
this Bob
you shall not to pass you shouts not
fast but if you close the door and open
and try to go again they're just running
around now out there you started you
shot one arrow started a whole thing
this town loves me nope
maybe a guy she went out on ran so I
imagine someone's gonna come and fight
you at some point right or is that just
gonna be forgotten about mmm that's a
good question I don't know I generally
yes but it's possible that she's just a
faker you know what this is a problem
this is definitely a problem uh is there
you're stuck in this room base I'm stuck
in this room and I think I need to order
incumbered I can probably maybe that's
part of it
that is justified but you eat something
eat a lot until you're not I'll get
drunk yes that's good
do when you get drunk do you feel the
effect again I haven't actually done
that yet
which I just dropped these I think you
just dropped them I did
oh I held ax you just got it oh great
and you time to fight we shall battle
them get out the sword I liked this
force fight like you can't do anything
you have to fight him don't drink before
you finally stop I can't don't you fight
I'm over in cover don't drink and fight
this is not going can you play when
you're over encumbered or no like can
you fight people I think so
damnit man you're getting bodied oh you
are just getting bodied
I'm letting him think that he has the
upper hand oh I see I see taking a few
punches let him waste his energy yeah
take a few hits and that's when you go
in for the kill yeah he's Swift
he's witty he's good with this axon
Jesus [ __ ] don't you dare say the Lord's
name in vain in this time of day I'm a
servant of God you Lily live up crap
it's around
nice game Rob is dead
christ almighty I don't think this
town's gonna like me after this
probably not Oh oh he okay he's
surrendered I won't kill him I won't
kill him let's talk buddy have him pay
dearly if you insist that's right give
me your monies oh my god all right time
oh now he's gonna start fighting again
oh he's running this is my life now I
despite people in this room it's the
late game listen buddy I don't mean any
harm I'm just gonna leave come on can
you leave yes he pushed you out down the
word Saddles let's book it let's get out
pebbles let's go time to later you
losers yeah nice you got it you just got
saved just now hell you kill kid
chickens and roosters you probably
offend people absolutely oh well this
town already hates my guts oh that's
fine
chicken it's actually a really realistic
thing this is how I like actually 1,400
chicken feather pecking what we really
worth okay ready I'm ready
come on batch again wait really it's
like I'm actually this isn't Crouch I
guess but wait this is knowing that
actually does something let's try this
dude they're supposed to like like
explode and then like what's left is
like a defend our you doing on my
chickens I'm just trying to spot your
chicken here nothing oh well funny you
asked let's talk a few things see bow
effects as we saw I'm just kidding I had
to play into it a little bit well gets
the game it's not you okay it's broken
you're right just blame the game when in
doubt your chickens suck let's see yeah
my reputation oh my god that is so funny
no I look I know I have a really like I
think that physical comedy is hilarious
so that got me I don't know why Oh jumps
like so high in the air dude pebbles has
got the best jump in the land
you can stab the chicken so skylock
alright let's go back and figure that
out I mean it really did bother you I
could tell you like you really did it
really bothered you because you knew
that you could do it but in the past I
mean it's a bummer and oh there's
chicken it's a bummer because yeah they
like explode let's try it again maybe
that that lot of chickens just sucked
okay you can take them know hey food you
have to do do not kill them and let it
go to waste
collect the chickens okay you so mad you
have to take revenge on every chicken
also how you pick them up leave this I
use caution you just shove your fist
right yeah that's realistic alright
alright now let's see what the
reputation is okay so guys now you know
Rob does not suck and he knows exactly
how to punch the chickens just right
this town doesn't like me it was just it
was the first chickens were bugged the
first lot first lot of chickens were
we're back let's talk well I'm surprised
this guy did not care at all I just took
all his chickens yeah
yeah she spend time with friends he was
a loner have you noticed anything
suspicious recently she was murdered
he was limping drunk sounds like a lot
of people back in the state yeah well he
drank a lot of ale we're out here
so I think we are wrapping up yeah just
about just about time okay we've had an
hour and a half in stream perfect that's
a pretty good stream I think we did a
lot we did a lot any any final thoughts
Rob on uh let's see I'm gonna I'm gonna
do the thing where we go back to the
full camp sure hit final thoughts
um well mm-hmm I like this game it got a
little wacky in the end but this games
fun it's you know if you can put up with
the bugs as you saw a few some you know
the first one was kind of game breaking
which is a bummer but the chicken bug
door bug the door bug chicken Bob the
horse gang stuck on the fence bug the
love quest bug where the lady just
disappeared swipe left yeah then you can
you know as long as from what you've
seen you can kind of put up with it then
go for it otherwise maybe and you're
still interested then I would say hang
tight and see if it gets patched or
updated yes I think if you like Skyrim
this game is for you if you like
medieval things this game is probably
for you if you like games that are silly
sometimes this game is definitely for
you definitely if you don't like
violence probably not for you probably
right if if you know yeah if you don't
like intestines kind of spilling on ya
if you don't like a random naked man
every once in a while you know probably
not for you but it seems like it could
be a lot of fun and I'm looking forward
to see how the game changes and
progressives and is fixed over time and
the mods yeah that's gonna be PC yeah
definitely yeah the mods will be
interesting and entertaining for sure so
thank you guys so much for joining us on
today's stream I will be here next
Thursday mhm and I don't know what we're
gonna be playing I think last week I
told you guys maybe a battle royale but
you know you never know really these
days so I don't know stay tuned yeah and
we will see you soon see you guys bye
okay Eric I think I got it right this
time okay right ready ready spin it wait
hold on I know it alright bye bye
nailed it